all we need to do is go take a look at
the public health statistics that are
gathered by the states themselves the
states that reformed their cannabis laws
several years ago and to understand the
effects of that reform and if you do
what you find is a very consistent
pattern alcohol sales down binge
drinking down use suicide down domestic
violence down violent crime down
Medicaid reimbursements down opioid
prescriptions down opioid fatalities
down 25% in medical cannabis states
right we know that cannabis can help
soldiers readjust to peacetime we know
that it can help couples work their
disputes out in a more peaceful way
there's this whole body of effects that
cannabis has that I call the overlooked
wellness benefits of cannabis right and
obviously they include things like
epilepsy and Alzheimer's all the grave
illnesses that cannabis can help
ameliorate or even cure right but
there's a whole other body of things
that cannabis can do and I'm thinking
about the way that cannabis can extend
your patience and wake up your sense of
play can spark your creativity can
heighten your appreciation of nature can
teach you ways to resolve disputes more
peacefully right all of these things
that the way that cannabis can deepen
your appreciation of the flavor of a
meal or the sound of music right or the
touch of your lover's skin the way that
cannabis can help a poet find just the
right word or a painter finding just the
right color or a musician finds just the
right note these things are not like
they're not about getting high they're
not about escaping they're not about
getting blotto cannabis is about
enhancing the most valuable and precious
parts of our lives
[Music]